كريم وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين واشهد ان لا
اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
يقول الحافظ النووي رحمه الله في رياضه في
الباب الاول منه باب احضار النيه
باب الاخلاص واحضار النيه في جميع الاقوال
والاحوال والاعمال البارزه والخفيه في
الحديث الثامن منه وعن ابي موسى عبد الله
بن قيس الاشعري رضي الله عنه قال سئل رسول
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم عن الرجل يقاتل
شجاعه
ويقاتل حميه
ويقاتل رياء اي ذلك في سبيل الله فقال
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم من قاتل
لتكون كلمه الله هي العليا فهو في سبيل
الله متفق عليه
رياض الصالحين
sincerity
‏in all acts of worship whether they be
spoken inward out whether they be in
action
in all of being
here on the ابي عبد الله قيس الاشعري
ابو موسى رضي الله عنه
عرف بكنيته
اكثر مما عرف باسمه الا انه
ليس مغمورا في الكنيه كما كان ابو هريره
رضي الله عنه مثلا فهو معروف بابي موسى
ويعرف ايضا في كتب الحديث بعبد الله بن
قيس
رضي الله عنه هو الاشعري
الاشعري
وهذا نسبه الى
الاشعر وهي قبيله بني بنو اشعر قبيله من
اليمن معروفه
وهذا الاشعر هو
اب هذه القبيله وهذا لقبه لقبه الاشعر قيل
ان اسمه
اي قيل ان اسمه اي خالد او
ابن ادد
ا ابن يخشب
وهو من قبائل اليمن
وقيل سمي الاشعر او لقب بالاشعر لانه حين
ولدته امه
كان جسمه كثير الشعر
جاء مع الشعر على جميع جسمه فقيل له
الاشعر يعني ذو الشعر الكثير
الكثيف
فهو اب هذه القبيله
وابو موسى رضي الله عنه هاجر
ثلاث مرات كيف
اسلم حين سمع بالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
وقدم عليه في مكه
ثم حاجر
الى الحبشه
ثم جاء من الحبشه
مع جعفر بن عبد المطلب
ومن معه الى المدينه وقدموا بعد خيبر
بقليل وضرب لهم النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
سهما
يعني لمن قدم من الحبشه ضرب لهم سهما في
مغانب
في مغانب
ال في مغانم
خيبر رضي الله عنه فالنبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم مدح ابا موسى الاشعري وكان ولاه
في الولايات
في اليمن وارسله الى اليمن قاضيا وحاكما
وعالما يعلم الناس وداعيه الى الله سبحانه
وتعالى توفي ابو موسى الاشعري في السنه
الثانيه بعد الاربعين او الرابعه بعد
الاربعين من الهجره ابو موسى الاشعري
مجهره
اليمن هجره مكه
صلى الله عليه
الحبشه
المدينه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ابو موسى الاشعري
بخاري مسلم صلى الله عليه وسلم
لقد اوتيت مزمار
من مزامير ال داود
الله عليهص والسلام
bir
الله سبحانه وتالى
عليه الصلاه والسلام ابو موسى الاشعري
صلى الله عليه وسلم
زكاه
رضي الله عنه ابو موسى الاشعري
years old
العراق ابو موسى الاشعري
حديث
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ابو موسى الاشعري رضي الله عنه
was
even though arrived مهاجرين
after fined
their intention what meaning they
arrived before
they would
‏from
[Silence]
موسى الاشعري
ابو هريره
عثمان
backل
‏was
however
was notwi
in
under the tree
‏areثم
was not
place because
wasenter
toah and come back
him and so they assumed was killed
captured which is an act of
صلى الله عليه وسلمعه
عثمان رضي الله عنه
بيعه الرضوان
‏in we said before int are
a person has the intention and is able
to do the act they rewarded for the
intention and the act a person has the
intention and tries to do it but is
unable
they are rewarded for the intention and
the act a person has the intention
‏in to andc
doinges
against doing this person is rewarded
for their intention and we mention this
at the begin of
عثمان
شرعا شرعا
الحقيقه الشرعيه انه كان من اهل بدر
وان كانت الحقيقه
حقيقه العاده او حقيقه الجسم او الاجسام
او الواقع او الحس
الحقيقه الحسيه لم يكن موجودا
صلى الله عليه وسلم تبوك
however
back of because of
‏sickness illness
they got last minut they unable to
attend they tried to come they unable to
attend thee of came between them and
what they attempt to do so they are
reward for the intention and for the act
for this reason you find that when the
schar mention that was not in the battle
of that meysically he was
الله
ابو موسى الاشعري
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
ان شاء الله الله اعلم صلى الله وسلم على
نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
والحمد لله